not kind of saw that the state
guarantees security so if there's no
freedoms and security without state so
if there are any ideas or beliefs that
could potentially threaten the stability
of the state then that'sthat's a good
reason to limit and prevent people from
from holding those ideas and he also
mentioned and you were correct when you
mention about Mohammed ins right so he
said that Mohammed ins don't have a
claim for toleration as we've got the
court here actually yeah if you can read
out the exact quote so that people I've
got the one for atheism though yeah
it says here those those are not at all
to be tolerated who deny the being of a
God promises covenants and and oaths
which are the bonds of human society can
have a can have no hold upon an atheist
yeah
he says the to the taking away of God
though but even in thought dissolves all
besides also those that by their atheism
undermined and destroy all religion can
have no pretense of religion whereupon
to challenge the privilege of toleration
yeah so clearly I mean this is joy once
again John look he's opposing I actually
know what iíve got the I have the quotes
here actually and this is in I think
took a chapter 20 of us yeah there you
go
so he says I'll try to kind of I'll just
talk about the Muslim side of it so he
talks about he alludes to Catholics and
then he says and this probably sounds
like some Islamic folks today right he
says it is ridiculous for anyone to
profess himself to be a muhammad in'
only in his religion but in everything
else a faithful subject to a christian
magistrate which bases government whilst
at the same time he acknowledges himself
bound to yield a bit blind obedience to
the mufti of constantinople who himself
is entirely obedient to the ottoman
emperor basically the caliph and frames
the feigned Oracle's or columns of the
identities what hook misses Oracle's but
it means outcome of that religion
according to his pleasure pleasure
and this muhammad in living amongst
Christians would yet more apparently
renounced their government if he
acknowledged
the same person to be head of his church
who is the supreme magistrate in the
state
so basically Muslims can't be trusted
yes because they're the the head of
their religion or their leader is the
Caliph it isn't the leader of the
Christian State they live in the
conflict of interest yes which is why
he's argues that it is ridiculous just
to think that we should only that with
that Muslim can only be can only be a
Muslim in a spiritual aspect and not in
a political aspect - right so it shows
you I'm intrigued the extent to which
liberalism is malleable from the inside
and elastic if you like is all from from
it's very fun outside because obviously
here if toleration can be stretched
according to public good and community
interest and social interest to this
extent then to what extent is liberalism
in fact individualistic in this in the
sense I claims to be you know it's it's
gonna be as we would call HD handy right
yeah I got something from Miller so I
know we're kind of skipping 200 years
it's all right
but this is what I found quite just
interesting I mean I'm not sure once
again I think I was talking to you about
this before but I'm not sure if this is
authentic or not so I have to put as a
big caveat in before I read this out but
he's talking about blasphemy sure and
blasphemy laws and he says yeah if such
prosecutions be necessary for the
well-being of the community
if the prosperity of England requires
that some martyrs should be made by the
religion for which so many have been
made in former times then by all means
let them continue and be multiplied and
let Christianity which benefits the
country in so many other ways also
benefit by the sacrifice of its own
character for mercy toleration and
consistency it is however worth well
worth considering whether we will be
reduced to style Emma so otherwise here
I'm not sure once again up as a caveat
I'm not sure to what extent this is
accurate but what Mills seems to be
indicating here as well once again fast
wording a hundred fifty years or 200
years or whatever it may be is that
there are certain things
that society are unacceptable and
therefore should be universalized in law
and and those things would then be used
to curtail human interaction and liberty
if you like from an individual I got one
more example of looking at this because
this could be contested manuscript right
but in page 166 on Liberty very famous
book he basically John Stuart Mill talks
about certain acts which are done
publicly and not acceptable and he talks
of you know potentially like for example
about like a husband wife having sex
Marshall if he talks about himself life
but is from a second resource to maybe a
husband wife having sex in public right
so this kind of thing sex in public is
an unacceptable offense
according to even I think law today its
public yes yes it's not lawful
percentage guys even though you might
think it's not in by some people's
antics we hear about on the news and so
on but no it's generally prohibited it's
prohibited yeah that kind of thing so if
there is something which can be
universalized in law and enshrined in
law in such a way as would prevent human
beings from enacting their kind of
individual or doing what they want to do
individually then according to mill and
Locke and all of those theorists once
again there is a intrinsic malleability
or we can say such a malleability eyes
ironically would allow for rigidity at a
certain stage you can't be free at all
stages because you could argue this
doesn't harm anyone it goes against the
harm principle right yeah so you know
two people having sex maybe could harm a
child but if they do in the same area
yeah you know I mean why not you know
Quantic wanted it's their Creed
according to the Creed and so the point
I'm making is that it's always I'm
probably this is probably a good way to
segue into this there's always going to
be that tension between social contract
the universality of law and the
individual self-expression
so this is a problem for liberalism
right how does you how do human being so
out these things especially when you put
democracy into thee because I think I
saw you one time on YouTube you are
you're not sure if this is correct you
can correct me wonderful you questioning
someone on on like I think it was Middle
Eastern context and you were talking
about politics and say for example let's
just be controversial here and this is
kind of bringing out right I think me
controversial so one of the punitive
laws of these are kinds at the hand of
the thief
for example say for instance which is in
the Quran okay and we're not saying it's
applicable for all times and places
certainly we're not saying it's
applicable in the United Kingdom right
for the non-muslims or whatever it may
be right we're not gonna say we cut the
hands off we were judge judy and
executioner judge jury sure yeah yeah
but what I was gonna say was that say
for instance right we're bringing the
democratic element right you have a
society which the majority principle
dictates from for in for example in a
referendum decide that this this should
be the method by which and through which
thieves ought to be punished now you've
got lots of tensions here you've got the
tension between a social contract the
death the majority principle human
so-called human rights and the vigil
Human Rights which one should take
primacy in the in the struggle for
making it onto law what should be
enshrined and become universal as law
but well you like when people look at
her Dourdan a thing oh isn't that isn't
that so barbaric and so on no they don't
they don't look at let's say in look the
history of English law even during its
post enlightenment develops stage listen
19th century so it wasn't that long ago
in terms of history Victorian Britain
yeah if you if you commit theft you
could be executed you know and killed
and rendered dead just for committing
theft really the who do doesn't do that
it's non doesn't say it doesn't say that
is worth it's much more harsh yes
certainly much more harsh you also had
forced
for many petty crimes yes in so Bessey's
made into slaves but those who know
they'll say Abdullah look removed all
for that that was something of the pie
no I I know but I would argue they've
replaced it with something which is
still I would argue inhumane compared to
the shoddy of the mercy of the Sharia
because the Sharia the punishment system
is very it's usually it's corporal
punishments so punch him the ball of the
body but the person is released back to
their family that very day right their
family doesn't suffer when that person
is punished the person who commits the
planet commits the year that the crime
they're punished not their family but in
in Western countries they put people
into these cages humans they put humans
into cages for long periods of time
and have created human zoos it's become
an industry in United States of America
with the highest prison population in
the world more than China - got a
billion people is that is that correct
is accurate yeah it's the largest prison
population in the world not not as not
as a ratio as numbers of individuals as
numbers as numbers and we're paying I
think it's over I think that run a
million or so people and million
Americans are in cages and what I was
gonna say to you here going back to the
problems of liberalism
yeah because couldn't one easily argue
right just potentially as Locke John
Locke did and potentially as John Stuart
Mill fall is worth okay
would would indicate himself that I mean
this this might sound a bit wacky here
right but let's bring one of the abdomen
huddled for honest or now one of the
punitive laws of Islam right say for
example cutting the hands of the thief
well I could even bring us suppose an
execution death penalty not the flogging
for zina basically for yeah Ming
Xin yeah according to the logic of John
Stuart Mill here in 866 of his book on
Liberty if there are certain things
which are unacceptable publicly so this
this point it's unacceptable publicly
who's to who's to decide it would be
either either or there will be the the
population and all the
yeah so if it's the ruler and the
population so there's kind of like well
the majority principle if they want to
bring him democracy wherever it may be
but if that's the case so from this
logic you can actually justify using
liberal principles couldn't you I mean
couldn't you justify the cutting the
hand of a thief but they don't really
have an argument like John Locke John
Stuart Mill Thomas Hobbes Sonya Thomas
of Leda wouldn't could not actually
produce any argument to actually
criticize they might say it's against
our tastes to do so but they were doing
far worse in England round-nose at those
times much much worse then O'Neill
Empire mm-hmm I'm not sure what they
were their thing was I mean I read it in
two treatises of government is a lot
discussion on slavery and obviously
there's no doubt in the United States
they were amputated and putative knee
hands of of slaves that ran away and so
and so forth whereas in the Sharia you
don't know you can't amputate slaves and
so on and so forth but what I was gonna
say was that there's no doubt on John
Locke's position for example on slavery
he's unequivocally against it right he
talked about for the most part for irony
and it's there's some reports of him
actually having slaves but in America
okay what he did weigh against them and
that's from what from what I remember he
definitely wrote against it slavery is
an institution or what can I he
definitely wrote against against they
said the human being should never be
enslaved and so on to an extent he but
he also defended he defended slavery in
the Bible by arguing it wasn't exactly
are you probably I think he went to my
kind of Islam and slavery lecture when I
brought this up yes where he said that
if you're not allowed to execute your
slave at will and we're quantitive the
laws of Moses and what have you
after I think seven or six years you
release them or or that they can be
released if they pay off a debt or
what-have-you but basically you didn't
you don't have unconditional absolute
control over someone to do whatever you
want and we know that in Islam you don't
you know there's fish ins that there are
rights better safe has it over you so
Quinn to John Locke
that's not slavery mmm so Jewish the
kind of slavery did as defining Jewish
law and slavery as they
we would say is in Sharia or least how I
am Eric manages it according to John
Locke he isn't slavery and that's what
he writes in his two tiers of government
that you put that section on slavery he
writes he actually did it mentions it by
name which is saying that liberals would
find them probably disconcerting if they
knew that now and you're right what you
said about they these guys would not
have any crystal of the Sharia in fact
they could even argue I could be argued
that according to John Locke an Islamic
government under a caliph with it with
implementing Sharia is a free government
it's it's a free state on the basis that
he said the same thing about a Jewish
government no not even that he gave a
definition so Robert Robert filmer
argues that well if you believe in
freedom you believe that people can just
do whatever they want and he was real
buts in response they no no I didn't say
that
I what I meant by freedom is that you
live under a government with known laws
that apply for everybody equally where
the ruler can't do anything he wants to
just because he doesn't like you so I
don't like that hat you're wearing I'm
gonna kill you he can't do that
because the law is prohibited right all
the laws the laws of defined so whatever
is is within the permissible area and
the moba you have freedom that's what he
means by freedom